[Musique]
depuis le début de la pandémie les
chercheurs ont pu observer des
infections aux strass cov deux dans des
fermes d'élevage de visons chez certains
animaux domestiques et dans les eaux on
constate depuis peu que coronavirus a
fait son choix en milieu sauvage chez
les cerfs de virginie où on craint que
les animaux deviennent un réservoir pour
le virus
il n'était revenu pas ne pousse pas et
n'ont pas de symptômes apparents
n'empêche certains d'entre eux sont
infectées par le virus sras skov deux
responsables de lakovic 19 les premiers
cas ont été rapportés aux états unis on
compte aujourd'hui dessert infectées
dans 15 états américains
en iowa l'analyse de plus de 280
échantillon a laissé les chercheurs
pantois avec raison en iowa un cerf de
virginie sur trois étaient infectés
[Musique]
c'était étonnant et inattendu
on pensait découvrir quelques cas
positifs
mais après une première série de tests
la quantité de cas positifs nous a
vraiment surpris
des résultats qui ont ameuté les
responsables de la fonte chez nous
aujourd'hui on les ferme ni pourquoi la
commune on sait que les cerfs de
virginie sont plus vulnérables aux
infections du virus responsable de la
cobac 19
c'est qu'ils ont comme nous des
récepteurs à ce2 qui permettent au virus
de s'amarrer plus aisément aux cellules
saines pour ensuite déclenché une
infection
l'idée est de savoir jusqu'à quel point
le virus s'est répandu chez dessert noté
chantier est vraiment partout dans un
échantillonnage pancanadien ya beaucoup
de provinciaux qui collaborent à ce
projet-là de surveillance opportuniste
s'articule dauchez dessert
en novembre 2000 21 les biologistes
québécois ont prélevé des échantillons
sur plus de 250 cerf de virginie aussi
bien ici à downham en estrie cameron
spurs dans les laurentides
est ce que votre élevé
on prête des échantillons à des
couillons naveau les sanctions pour
détecter le virus de l'aco vide chez les
femmes c'est un aiguillon nasale jeu le
second prélèvement qu'on va faire ça va
être un prélèvement vraiment de sens
l'échantillon de sang permet de
déterminer si les serres qui ne sont pas
infectés aujourd'hui l'ont été dans le
passé leur sand à contenir des anticorps
développés pour combattre le coronavirus
masqué voulu le baby boy le plomb et si
la sauce et la carte pki est requise
pour les tests
trois semaines plus tard la nouvelle
tombe le canada confiance et premiers
cas
trois serres sont infectés par le coran
navires us en estrie dans le lot
d'échantillons de dunham on note aussi
la présence d'anticorps dans le sens de
certains animaux
ces quatorze sarr qui ont été confirmés
le avec des handicaps donc ça nous donne
l'équivalent environ 1 9 % lors de cinq
des anticorps au moment où on ne fait
les prélèvements en novembre dernier
dans les laurentides par contre aucun
cas ailleurs au pays on a confirmé
quatre cas en saskatchewan 3 au manitoba
et 17 en ontario
[Musique]
comment expliquer un si grand écart
entre le nombre de cerfs effecté au
canada - 2 % comparativement à plus de
temps pour cent aux états unis mais
c'est un moment si c'est difficile de
pouvoir donner une explication claire
parce qu'on ne connaît pas
nécessairement les différentes sources
et de transmission du virus chez les
cervidés sauvage
l'écart pourrait s'expliquer par
l'activité désert au moment des
échantillonnages la densité d'animaux au
kilomètre carré le taux d'infection de
la population locale ou leur proximité
avec des humains
qu'un enfant par exemple j'ai une pomme
à moitié mangé par la fenêtre ou qu'une
personne se soulageant forêt et le virus
se diffuse les serres ne suivent pas nos
règles d'hygiène un contact avec un de
ses éléments et ils pourraient attraper
la maladie et que
la véritable crainte c'est que les cerfs
de virginie devienne un réservoir à long
terme pour le virus et quand c'est à
l'intérieur d'une population d'animaux
sauvages ça devient plus complexe
une fois que c'est fait notre capacité à
prédire quelle direction le virus soit
prendre est limitée
qui le virus va t'il infectés qui va s'y
adapter qui va transmettre quoi à qui ça
devient très difficile à suivre et de
fuck up
c'est un virus de la lignée du variant
delta qui a infecté les serres au québec
mais le variant au micron a aussi à
terre récemment dessert en banlieue de
new york en ontario une recherche
préliminaire rapporte la présence d'une
ligne et unique du strass cov 2 chez
certains c'est très important de pouvoir
faire une surveillance continue pour
vérifier par exemple si le virus par
ailleurs avoir des mutations qui
augmenterait par exemple sa
transmissibilité sa virulence qui
pourrait avoir un impact chez laffont
pour chez lui même ou six
les cerfs de virginie peuvent s'infecter
entre eux c'est démontrer mais pour la
première fois la publication
préliminaire des chercheurs canadiens
suggère un cas de transmission du cerf
de virginie a lui même en ontario
pour les chasseurs donc une attention
accrue s'impose battons pour la
consommation de la viande puisque le
virus ne survivra pas une bonne cuisson
plus tôt durant la manipulation de la
carcasse
doivent prendre des précautions pour
éviter de d'être en contact direct être
exposée par exemple des éclaboussures
lorsqu'ils manipulent par exemple est
reçue respiratoires donc le port du
masque bien ajustés recommandé mais ceci
à d'autres équipements de protection
lorsqu'on fait des passages de barrages
de carcasses serait qu'ils le font par
exemple dans l'ue 28
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent aucun autre animal
sauvage tester au canada n'a été déclaré
positif à une infection par le
coronavirus
l'analyse des 3000 échantillons de
cervidés au pays se poursuivent et les
spécialistes ne sont pas sans penser à
ce qui pourrait nous pendre au bout du
nez
quand la maladie s'établir sans espèces
sauvages comme avec le cerf de virginie
ça devient presque impossible de
l'éradiquer
avec des millions de cerfs de virginie
qui se promènent sur tout le continent
on comprend que l'enjeu est grand
[Musique]
non